LAURA LING: Matt Tilford
was just 18-years-old
and two weeks away
from graduation
when, on a camping
trip with friends,
his truck sped off a
cliff, falling 600 feet.
MATT TILFORD: The truck
started to tumble,
and I wasn't
wearing my seatbelt.
I was ejected as we were
going down the hill.
LAURA LING: Do you
remember going off
that cliff and landing?
MATT TILFORD: I was going
in and out of consciousness,
and I didn't realize
until I looked down.
And that's when I realized, it's
like, oh man, I am paralyzed.
This is serious.
[SOMBER MUSIC]
LAURA LING: As someone who
thrived in the outdoors
playing sports, Matt
was suddenly confronted
with an entirely new reality.
MATT TILFORD: I was
definitely freaking out.
I was thinking of my future,
what I was going to do.
LAURA LING: He had to
relearn the most basic tasks,
like how to get dressed,
wash, move around.
MATT TILFORD: After my
accident, I came home
and I was depressed.
I didn't want to leave home.
Watching my friends go off to
college and start their life,
I felt left behind.
LAURA LING: Four
years later, Matt
got a life-changing
opportunity to test out
a new exoskeleton
rehabilitation device being
designed by Ekso Bionics.
What was that like, to put
on that exoskeleton suit?
How did that feel?
MATT TILFORD: It felt
absolutely amazing to be
bearing my own weight,
my legs holding myself up
within that device.
It was surreal.
LAURA LING: The suits help
people with spinal cord
injuries, or those who
have suffered a stroke,
stand and take
steps, something many
are told they'll never
be able to do again.
How does the technology
work, and how does it
work with the body?
RUSS ANGOLD: Think of
it as a wearable robot,
and it has four actuators that
replace the user's muscles.
And then the user
interacts with it
by actually shifting
their weight,
just like you would
go to take a step.
LAURA LING: The exoskeletons are
accessible around the country
at hospitals for
rehabilitative uses,
in hopes that one day the
patient will no longer need
the suit to walk.
RUSS ANGOLD: By having that sort
of interaction where they're
in control of the device, that
keeps the signals coming down
from the brain, trying to walk.
At the same time, they're
getting that therapy,
and their legs are going
through a very natural gait.
So that signal's
getting sent back up,
and that's really what you want
is that collision of signals
to help with the
neuroplasticity and to help
them regain that ability
to walk without the device.
LAURA LING: Given the
scope of Matt's injuries,
it's unlikely he'll ever
walk without an exoskeleton,
but that doesn't
mean the suit doesn't
have other major benefits.
MICHAEL GLOVER: It gives them
that sense of independence back
a little bit.
There are other benefits
just of being upright.
You might have improvements
of your bowel and your bladder
function.
Some people have some pain
stemming from their nerves
because they're just in
that improper position.
That sometimes goes
away with some folks.
LAURA LING: So this is the
history of some of the things
that you've built
over the years.
RUSS ANGOLD: Exactly right.
They go all the
way back to 2006.
This was our
[INAUDIBLE] exoskeleton.
This is a medical exoskeleton
that has six actuators, so
powered ankles.
Some devices for
powering your knees
for military applications.
And the last one's our
industrial chassis prototype
for construction
industrial workers.
LAURA LING: The history of
the exoskeleton goes way back.
In 1890, Russian
inventor Nicholas Yagn
patented the first exoskeleton
powered by compressed gas bags
to assist with blocking,
jumping, and running.
Whether it was ever
built is unknown.
In the 1960s, General
Electric and the US military
created the Hardiman suit using
electricity and hydraulics,
but the device was so dangerous
and uncontrollable it was never
powered on with a person inside.
Even more recent models
in the early 2000s
were considered too heavy.
But around 2005,
battery technology
became a game changer.
RUSS ANGOLD: We figured out
how to do it efficiently.
We had the lightweight
materials and structures,
and then we had the
computing processing power,
which is a key one to
actually bring it all together
and make it work.
LAURA LING: Other companies,
such as suitX and ReWalk
Bionics, are designing
suits for patients
to use in their everyday
lives at a price
tag of around $70,000 per suit.
Ekso is also working
on technology
that could potentially impact
the over 17 million people
in the construction industry,
who perform rigorous work
with heavy machinery.
RUSS ANGOLD: We now have a
product out there that really
makes their tools weightless.
And that doesn't seem
like much until you
try to operate a 35-pound
tool all day long,
and it's just exhausting.
LAURA LING: It's true, though.
I mean I can't imagine
doing that up and down
up and down all day long.
RUSS ANGOLD: Right,
so now grab it.
There you go.
LAURA LING: Oh wow.
It is weightless.
That's amazing.
What do you think the potential
is in this technology?
MICHAEL GLOVER: I'm not sure
that I can see an end point.
I believe that there could
be those pants one day,
that is your exopants that
are so low profile that it
can support somebody.
LAURA LING: For
now, Matt continues
to test Ekso Bionics technology
and rediscover the ability
to do things he once
thought would be impossible.
MATT TILFORD: I wanted to
prove people that I was still
going to be OK.
I still going to be successful.
I learned how to still
be active with sports.
I waveboarded and
snowboarded, and once I did,
it was absolutely amazing.
LAURA LING: What does
it feel like when
you're in the suit today?
MATT TILFORD: I think every
time I go from sit to stand,
a smile comes on my face.
Just knowing that I'm at eye
level with everyone else.
It's going to give
people the opportunity
to do things that they
weren't able to do before.
And it's cool to be at
the forefront of it.
LAURA LING: On another
episode of Seeker--
TRACE DOMINGUEZ: It's
taken hundreds of years
to understand how Earth's
magnetic field works.
But now that we
do, scientists are
trying to find hints
from Earth's history that
might reveal the future of this
ever-changing invisible field
all around us.
LAURA LING: Thanks
for watching, and be
sure to subscribe to Seeker.
[MUSIC PLAYING]